how does it feel have you have you shot
the final episode yet we have we we just
shot it about a month ago and it's what
good emotional filming the last oh yeah
I
I mean it's emotional now and it's been
a month right I for real was getting
massage yesterday
now who's bragging I was getting massage
yesterday a guy who says as a massage
therapist I as I was getting a massage
I felt tears streaming down my face I
was thinking about the last scene man I
didn't I shot together it's still like
very fresh yeah I don't know I mean I
guess I'm a freak but I I'm still very
much about it yes yes shooting that last
episode even just shooting the last
season it was everything that was like
oh well that's a wrap on this yeah like
you know this set or this actor or
whatever this is the last of the moment
yeah yeah well you are so exceptionally
talented you're gonna go and on to so
many other things you already have what
was that noise I just weep
oh I weep for the compliment it's so
nice Conan Jesus okay you didn't really
weep do you want me to kiss that's like
you were anesthetize in a small cat